[Applause]
so what you were on a classic TV show
when you were a kid that I did not know
about until before this interview I was
we were you know diving into your past
and I was like wait what I was like
barely on it I was on Barney when I was
a kid
it was huge but I was in like if you
blink you would have missed it you were
on it I wasn't on it I wasn't cool like
frisbee thrower one and my mom got to be
on it with me they were like do you want
to be on it she's like yeah and then I'm
in the very background and I'm just like
[Laughter]
um okay so well I know you just got
engaged so congratulations
[Applause]
so cute how handsome is he
um and I love wherever you're at oh yeah
that was we were wedding venue shopping
yeah I was like well you should pick
there that's pretty yeah so we met at a
mutual friend's birthday party uh um a
bar and then
um
we like hit it off and then I added him
on Facebook this is how long ago it was
I've used Facebook in many years but oh
wow on Facebook yeah that isn't it weird
how people date now yeah I know I don't
but other
s I'm just like that sounds exhausting
but it is weird like social media how
people like meet yeah it just feels it
can I don't know I always give afraid
that you're gonna get catfished or
something like I know I'm glad that we
met at a bar first before the social
media thing yeah I'm scared of that too
yeah you're a liar watch too many
episodes of that show yeah I've never
watched one because I'm already afraid
yeah no it's terrifying
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]